you actually you mean a lot to me
because it was like 2002 like I said I
think I realized I was gay like 11 12
years old that happened and then I
remember it was just seeing you on TV
and watching everyone fall in love with
you for just what it seemed like
effortlessly being yourself and being so
talented and that was just such a like
thriving course for me no I mean all my
friends at home are watching like Matt
don't cry don't don't do it don't lose
your because I've had the opportunity to
meet you like three times and I'll get
like four steps towards you and I'll be
like nope
it's funny because I remember being like
truly 12 13 years old and you remember
how like in Middle School you'd have to
fill out those get to know you cards
when you get to a new class so it's like
what's your favorite color what's your
favorite food who's your favorite singer
and like I said I was very closeted and
so I felt like if I put Kelly Clarkson
on there that'd be like gay but but so
and so and so that's so true well and so
I'm from Long Island it was like and so
I was like I feel like I had to fit in
yeah so who I would put from my favorite
singer was always Limp Biscuit oh my God
you went like so like I went all the
white head around yeah and it's no
offense still at Fred Durst and the girl
poorly I just love that you went very
well because it was like panic panic
panic I was like how do I see him like
the straightest guy in class and I was
like Limp Biscuit and then he didn't
want to put a Moment Like This
[Music]
I really wish this guy would have put a
Moment Like This down
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]